[Musique]
j'ai peur qu'on commence à déconnecter
les autres en train de me
parler tu crois que c'est pour toi de
vivre dans unel
chantier avec les ms je te
l' FAM la tu peux m à rés ce
problème je veux merilleuxureux
[Musique]
fam soit dans la mienne ne serait-ce
qu'une journée j'aimerais tellement que
tu saches ce que c'est d'être moi
j'adoreris avaler des tonnes de boîtes
de gâteau et les éliminer dans la foulée
vous voulez bien prendre une photo de
toute la famille et maintenant vous
allez tous dire joyeux Noël tout le
[Musique]
monde qu'est-ce que tu fais dans mon lit
c'est toi qui dans mon
lit qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est
moi
maman
papa c'est une situation qui s'est
jamais produite avant j'ai nouveau 17
ans je
vain il un souci avec un souci
aveces on doit passer le de cette
journée et comprendre comment ça a pu
arriver à mon épo le lycée céit la ruche
et moi j'ta le MI tu m'as volé mon
premier baiser non je me suloign donc tu
as aussi rejeté
Ariana comment j'ai pu penser qu'on
allait réussir qui est le boss ok montre
est le boss montre qui est le
boss vous devriez songer à réparer ce
qui a été brisé on va s'en sortir on est
les walkers et les walkers vont toujours
au bout des choses cramp ah je me suis
dchiré un coadrille tout ce qui compte
pour moi c'est que tu sois heureuse il
nous reste 24 he si on trouve pas une
solution on restera coincé pour toujours
ça fait des années que j'ai pas fait un
truc aussi excitant quelle que soit la
suite on la
vivleauchemar etut qu'
ré le chien et le bébé passent peut-être
un peu trop de temps
ensemble